hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 13 video everybody
give a hand to John Barrowman for an
amazing performance careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode there
were some great WTF s there is a new
round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
going on - is gonna stay open till I
post my legends of tomorrow video
tomorrow so let's start with top 5 WTF
and I'll try to work through Easter eggs
as we go along there were a lot of
internal Easter eggs things that they
referenced that happen in previous
seasons the title of the episode sins of
the father was mostly about Merlin sins
but it was also about Rochelle go about
nYSSA's father sins that racial goal in
Felicity's father's sins that it goes
beyond that usually episode titles are
meant to be really meta so you could
take a bunch of different meanings but
number five WTF calculator meets with
Felicity tries to make amends even if
you don't know anything about him in the
comics they actually played this in a
very real-world way they played this
like a totally normal family that had
been broken and like the dad shows up
after 18 years the highest level of
comic book that Felicity's Arc achieved
was when they were talking about Palmer
tech they were talking about little
devices like the data extraction device
the calculator left inside Palmer tech
Felicity's like yeah he failed my test
hard core the great thing about
calculator in this episode and I love
the way that he played it the actor that
plays calculator you probably remember
him from some other berlanti serious
like Everwood is that he seems really
genuine he's not lying about how he
cares about Felicity but he's a total
villain through and through just like
Malcolm in this episode John Barrowman
as Merlyn blurred the lines a little bit
better I think but he swung to number 4
WTF double-crossing Nyssa booming
villain Darth Vader voice this is fun
John Barrowman he's definitely having
fun in this episode Merlin's been pretty
subdued this season I mean he did scoop
up vandal savage's ashes so he's still
got those somewhere but John Barrowman
is this great theater actor and usually
that involves acting in a much bigger
way because you're actually playing to
live people in an audience instead of
just a camera with microphones so the
best comic book Merlyn seems like when
he goes into comic book villain
territory or scenes like this when he
gets to be way over the top when he gets
to be batshit crazy number 3 WTF open
League war in the streets
does this not remind you of season 3
when Oliver came back and they had that
big fight with bricks gang in the middle
of the street I like the way they did it
this season better it was a little bit
there were a few err number of extras so
the camera was able to get in a little
bit closer you saw a bunch of randos
getting dropped by arrows like just
stepping out of the alley oh my god
people trying to eat their dinner as
team arrow weaves through him knocks
aniseh out takes her puts her in a cage
just like last year she was talking
about season three when she came to
assassinate Merlin because she thought
that he was the one to kill Sara Thea
went to visit her gave her the sword was
like please kill me I need to pay for
what I did for killing Sarah because
Thea did kill Sara this is where Laurel
comes in she had a great arc in this
episode she tries to explain to Nyssa
that she's not bound by the rules of her
father the League of Assassins she could
do whatever she wants she's completely
free and I like the way they say your
father is dead but we're actually gonna
see the Matt Nabal Rachel Ghul on
legends of tomorrow I don't know which
episode it's gonna happen but it's gonna
happen so yeah he's dead in present-day
but he will come back somehow I'm
assuming it's gonna be when they go to
the past like we saw damian darhk-- in
the past
we'll see Rachel Google I just don't
know which era it's gonna be in number
two WTF
Oliver versus Merlyn round two on the
roof this is a direct continuation of
their fight from the season 1 finale if
you remember they had this awesome fight
at the end of that season
Oliver was so pissed like he found out
that Merlyn was a dark Archer
responsible for the undertaking so he
was gonna make Merlyn pay but he got
away so their fight went unfinished so
you could think of this episode is being
like sins of the father but also
unfinished business thing is though he
chops his hand off I actually thought
that he was gonna have to kill him but I
didn't think that John Barrowman would
die I thought they would find some other
solution because John Barrowman is
listed on all the other episodes for the
rest of the season on IMDB sometimes
that doesn't always play out sometimes
there's false information on IMDB but I
didn't think they'd kill Missa and I
didn't think they killed Merlyn off
matter settled although now Merlyn has
unfinished business with Oliver he's
like I'm not gonna kill you because that
would be mercy compared to what I'm
gonna do to you now this is where Merlyn
is gonna get really fun John Barrowman
is gonna have so much fun doing all
these crazy Merlin scenes now crazy
Merlin is so much better than Thea's dad
Merlin I mean I love the dad scenes that
he has with Thea but I feel like that
will slowly come to a close like
Felicity kicks her father to the curb I
feel like Thea is gonna do that
eventually two people do not change even
though Oliver is really optimistic about
that he's like I like to believe that
some of us can show
change but just as a funny sidebar how
awesome was it that Nyssa kept referring
to all of her as her husband by league
standards I'm your husband so I asked to
fight for you
so I guess Nyssa is like his work wife
and Felicity is his home wife who knows
how they figure that out but if you are
wondering yes so Nyssa is still married
to Oliver they just they never
consummated the marriage I don't really
know what the particular zuv that are
and why they've chosen to stay married
maybe it's just because there is no such
thing as divorced in the legal if
there's no way to accomplish that until
one of you dies but finally number one
WTF Nyssa burns her father's ring the
ring of the race and releases all the
assassins Merlyn vows revenge by telling
damian darhk-- about all of her son
so you left in this really WTF confusing
situation where you're like wait a
minute did they just kill the League of
Assassins if they've disbanded and
there's no mark of leadership then do
they still exist
it's like WTF what's gonna happen I
don't think that's gonna stick I think
there will always be a League of
Assassins
they'll just choose to address it in
some roundabout way in the future I
think they just want to take that crutch
away from Oliver Merlyn was in control
of the league Merlyn wanted to help Thea
so Merlyn could always bring the league
in if necessary but now they can't do
that anymore there's no lead to right in
and help them with hive and on top of
that now that Merlyn seems like he's
parlaying with damian darhk-- it seems
like Merlin's earlier comments Oliver
about laying his boat if damian darhk--
asked you to lay your bow down to save
your son william would you do it Oliver
is like WTF face oh my god how did you
know about my son I will say right off
the bat I do not think that his son is
the one that's in the grave first off we
barely gotten any exposure to him his
son is like this little plot point way
off in the distance it's just more
misdirection I feel like the whole point
of this episode in this arc with Thea
wasn't to undo what happened in season 3
because season 3 was the battle for Thea
so I knew that she wasn't gonna die so
it's almost like the writers have
restored Merlyn to his villain self
everyone else in the episode seems
relatively unchanged psychologically
Felicity Oliver Nyssa they didn't change
their alignment none of them changed
their relationships
Merlin's the only one who flipped so I'm
looking forward to very fun things from
Merlin's character but damian darhk-- is
the real focus for the back half of the
season they said there
redoubling just like the flash is
doubling down on its zoom plot in the
back half they're gonna do the same
thing on arrow with damian darhk-- that
means we're gonna learn what they're
trying to do with this mystery crop with
this mystery device damian darhk-- has
what this new beginning is that he's
been teasing let me know in the comments
though what was your favorite moment
from the episode and what do you think
about one-handed Merlin I feel like they
were doing the Star Wars thing where
it's like if he's gonna be the Darth
Vader of the series we're gonna have to
cut one of his hands off and it was
actually a pretty good episode
especially compared to where we were
last season around this time and I know
I promised to talk about Connor Hawke we
saw a teaser for him during the flash
last night that's who that was the green
arrow of another earth I don't know how
they're gonna explain it because we're
gonna see them on legends of tomorrow
but it's gonna be in star city of the
future Star City 2046
so Oliver's gonna have one arm like you
did during Frank Miller's Dark Knight
Returns comic book is gonna be pretty
badass but it's not til legends of
tomorrow Episode six so there's a couple
more weeks and I guess I should mention
it's not really an easter egg but
Felicity's mom mentioned Space Camp they
talked about Space Camp earlier this
season Felicity was like how come I
never got to go to Space Camp and her
mother explained what it was like to
raise her as a single parent like it was
this really sad story
so I should also say the actress that
plays Felicity's mom actually was great
in this episode she usually doesn't get
that many scenes and it's usually for
comedy she's usually really silly her
telling Felicity your dad has bad news
that was great but I feel like most of
the dads on arrow all around all around
even Quentin
not great dads they all love their
children Quentin is a good guy but he's
so flawed he's one of the better
examples of tragic heroes I feel like he
or Diggle are gonna be the one to end up
in the grave Quentin
Diggle and diggle's brother currently
maybe Lyla
so a new episode of Legends tomorrow ye
guys wait for that you can click here
for last night's episode of the flash
and you can click here to learn all
about how the Suicide Squad movie pretty
much killed Deathstroke on arrow
who knew Bennett's version of
Deathstroke thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight